good afternoon everybody let me first
dispel two doubts that you might have
first i'm not eric mamer
second i'm also not donna spinant
but i'm happy to replace them
and now i would like to give the floor
to anita who has an announcement on our
cooperation with moldova
anita
good afternoon
a request for assistance by moldova
yesterday the commission
has recommended to the council to open
negotiations for a status agreement
between frontex and the republic of
moldova
as you all know moldova is knee in need
of eu assistance due to the critical
situation caused by the war in ukraine
additional support is needed in the
accommodation of refugees as well as for
the border management functions
the status agreement will allow the
deployment of frontex teams to carry out
border management functions
tasks including registrations and border
checks under the leadership of the
moldovan authorities
more information is available on our
daily news
thank you
thank you very much anita and now the
floor is yours
um i'll go to um interaction so please
raise your hand your questions we have a
couple of questions here i see
we don't want to see
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
a
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
a
go ahead david
apparently your micro source is not the
correct one
you have disappeared in the virtual
space we don't see you anymore ah
hello yes david you're there okay thank
you thank you sorry apologies for for
this problem
the refugees
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
anita
[Music]
um
what do you say 162
frontext staff
[Music]
is
fuzzy
yes
my question was on
hungary and poland
[Music]
which are two other countries
subject to
quite important
influx of of refugees
and i'm wondering why
um frontex is not there
uh
moldavia moldova is not in the european
union
there are agreements and so on romania
has asked for frontex okay but
i'm wondering why poland and hungary are
not asking
um
the frontex to play its role in the
european union
i mean there are more people of frontex
in greece right now
to part two to to
and they are there when the great
government
uh is making some pushback
but they don't go to poland and to
and too hungary why
um i will come back to you on the
specific uh
uh data frontex is already uh just for
your background information in poland
they have been already uh
there before in the joint operation
terra
i can come back to you as regards the
the specific
number of stuff present there
thank you anita
daffy is your question no
it's not
we don't have any further questions do
we have any further questions on
frontex
no
then we reopen the floor and david is
back david go ahead
mike source of it
okay is this working now yes welcome to
the president welcome to the press room
hi thanks
um
two questions
this is not humanitarian affairs yeah
that was clear
it's on the sanctions
um
and yesterday we sanctioned a number of
uh chief executives and shareholders of
major companies
um i was just wondering if you could
clarify that so this is the personal
assets
of those individuals
but i was wondering does this
if it's not prevented by other eu
sanctions
does this still allow for trade
with the companies they're associated
with i mean they're very important
companies in the fields of
agriculture uh petrochemicals and then a
second question if i may
on agriculture um so you gave a very
clear answer yesterday the commission
that hungary cannot ban
um agricultural exports because of the
crisis because of the rising prices
that was very clear i was wondering
about candidate countries because serbia
the serbian uh prime minister president
sorry announced a ban can a candidate
country ban exports of agricultural
products
to the eu and to other countries thanks
for your first questions regarding the
sanctions
and the possibility or not of preventing
them
then we'll tell you all you need to know
thanks stefan indeed i'll take daffod
your first question and then second
question i'm looking into colleagues
and and they can get back to you uh just
a housekeeping point first of all david
i know that you sent me an email on on
the specific question and it's quite
detailed so if you allow me uh to look
into this in a little bit more detail
apologies for for the slight delay and
getting back to you on that but i need
to examine it of course uh with with my
experts these these are complicated
matters the one
point that i would give you as a
preliminary answer uh to your question
is that
first and foremost it's for national
authorities to actually enforce these
sanctions of course we here in the
commission uh work hard to monitor their
enforcement to ensure their uniform
application and of course are
increasingly given giving guidance to
member states as to how uh these rules
should work in practice but first and
foremost it's for it's for member states
to enforce these and this is
specifically the case for asset freezes
when an asset is frozen it's for the
national competent authorities in each
eu member state to make an assessment as
to what assets should be frozen and i
can't obviously then go in and comment
on specific cases from the podium but as
i said at the beginning of my answer
allow me to assess this further with my
colleagues and i will get back to you in
the course of the afternoon
um thank you very much
then there was the question on
banning exports from candidate countries
we'll have to get back to you on that
one
okay do we have any further questions on
sanctions
yes you can hear me um thank you i have
a question on sections but on trade
sanctions it might be for miriam i
wanted to ask for an update on the trade
measures against russia i'm talking
specifically on the removal of the most
favorite
most favored nation statues
under wto rules
since there seems to be a political uh
will among member states
uh to move forward at least i was
wondering what was the
what were the the next steps on this on
the commission side thank you
thank you very much and i believe miriam
is with us orbit virtually miriam could
you take this one
ah there you are ah there you go
it's been a long time
so yeah yeah
as explained there was strong support by
member states these mentions were
discussed last friday in the framework
of the trade policy committee
now we are discussing uh in order to
adopt them internally and also we are
discussing with like-minded partners in
order to do something jointly so they
will be announced
very soon and as i also explained these
measures will be adopted under the
sanctions legal base
thank you
thank you
do we have
any further questions on sanctions let's
stay in the sanctions i don't see
questions
anymore
nor in the room
so we open the floor to other topics
oliver
go ahead
uh hi hi
stefan i don't know if you see me and
hear me
we see
super that's awesome wonderful
um
i have a i have an energy question and a
military question so i'll just drop them
here and then you you split them up
the military question is um
can you explain to us the the genesis of
um high representative porrell's
announcement 12 or 13 days ago that the
european union would buy fighter jets
and give them to ukraine
because that doesn't seem to be going
anywhere and i'd be interested in how he
came up with
this idea and what they make of it and
if there's some sort of postmortem to
this
announcement that seemed to be a bit
vacuous in hindsight and secondly on
energy
when uh vice president timmermans and
commissioner
simpson presented the
action plan for safe and reliable energy
and so forth
they said about 50 to 60 billion
cubic meters of gas that's currently
coming from russia should come from
other lng or pipeline sources
they didn't give any countries where
they should come from has the commission
already figured out
where these
uh quantities of natural gas are going
to come from this year because he said
timaman said this is going to happen
this is possible this year do you
already know where it's coming from
thank you
um thank you oliver yes i'm going to cut
your two questions into quest two
questions let's first handle um the
question you had regarding
energy
um and tim will uh clarify things here
yeah well
you say i'll clarify things i mean what
i would do is is repeat what we've um
said uh several times on this matter
going back several months now so oliver
as you know we've been in in talks with
a number of partners
and we're looking to increase and we
already have increased the lng imports
we had a record level of lng imports in
january
and february of this year
big increase in arrivals from the
from the usa notably um but we're also
looking
we've been talking to other partners
such as qatar
so for one example norway algeria i mean
egypt we're we're talking about pipeline
gas and lng and you'll see in the
communication we talk about 50 bcm
of lng and 10 bcm of pipeline get gas as
well
these conversations are continuing with
with this whole range of international
partners uh and we will see how those
progress in in the coming weeks and
months we have the capacity um to
receive that amount of of gas and now
we're working on on how to get that in
thank you i think oliver you have a
follow-up question
yes thank you tim um the belgian prime
minister de craw uh suggested today in
an interview
that the commission should be empowered
to negotiate with lng providers on
behalf of the eu is that something that
that you would like to do that you would
consider helpful
and doable
i mean that's it's an idea as you say
that comes from the prime minister and
we know that in versailles from this
afternoon um heads of state and
government are going to be meeting
they're going to be discussing the
repower eu communication
which the commission presented and that
includes a number of ideas and one of
those is that the commission could
potentially
support member states
in terms of
mapping out and coordinating
supply of
of gas so it's an option which which is
being explored and let's see what the
the leaders think about that and how
they think that could or should be taken
forward
thank you
um let's stay in the uh
area of energy if we have any further
questions on energy now that tim is with
us
do we have questions on energy
not interactio in the room
no thank you very much tim
so now we will go to your other question
oliver
regarding the high representative
peter
good afternoon oliver and thank you for
the question well the genesis basically
is very simple the european union
responded to
uh to demands and to the needs uh as
flagged by ukrainian partners uh
regarding the needs for the ukrainian
freedom fighters and for the ukraine
army to help them to defend the country
in the light of the unprecedented
illegal aggression by putin's forces
and uh
since the ukrainian armed forces have
specific needs specific military needs
the european union and its member states
are of course committed to support
ukrainian armed forces in their efforts
to fight off this illegal aggression
and
that's why the decision was made to use
uh 500 million euros from the european
peace facility to support the provision
of legal and non-liberal little weapons
and to strengthen the capacity of
ukrainian armed forces to to to fight
off this uh this putin's aggression and
i can only add that the member states
are on board with these and they are
providing uh also bilateral support to
the ukrainian armed forces but bottom
line is that it is up to the specific
individual member state to decide
what and how they uh intend to provide
within the framework of
the eu assistance
which is linked to these 500 million
euros from european peace facility
thank you peter oliver you have a
follow-up
the ukrainians uh addressed you and said
we need fighter jets can you pay for
them and you said yeah we're going to do
that because you announced this publicly
that that's a big thing did you consult
with nato did you consult with polish or
bulgarian uh governments who have such
planes
how did you come up with this idea and
in general but how much of these
which are these 500 million euros have
you already spent and can you
can you save what you spent it on if not
on the on the jets
well the decision to uh to allocate 500
million from european peace facilities a
decision that was made by the european
union
based on the discussions within the
european union that's one thing on the
on the allocations or on using this
money i will have to check obviously
because we have developments ongoing
every day the bottom line is that based
on the allocation of this money the
member states can decide what exactly
and how they will be providing to
support ukrainian armed forces uh to
defend their people and to their cities
and
and their country so we will check and
get back to you on this particular issue
of disbursements
thank you peter
ikem is your question for peter
yes my question is for peter for on the
nuclear
deal with their own talks can i go ahead
yeah go ahead but we don't hear you very
well so um
try to speak loud
is it better now yes
thank you
yes peter can you please explain uh uh
in fact answer
what's the position of the eu can the uh
nuclear deal go ahead without russia
because we hear now that the u.s
accusing russia of of impeding the the
talks
what's the position of you
well it's not so much about the position
of the eu you know that high
representative of the eu is the
coordinator of the jcpoa and the jcpoa
is basically a deal between uh signatory
parties and one of the signatory parties
is russia so if
the one of the signatories leaves the
deal is no longer part of the deal and
it's up to the remaining members to deal
with it you know that before
united states were part of the deal they
they left the deal under president trump
now the talks are ongoing in order to
see how uh the united states can join
the deal and how can we bring the
nuclear deal back to the full compliance
and full delivery so it's really up to
the participants of the jcpoa to uh to
deal with the situation where it arises
at this stage is not really for us to
speculate i can only say that russia is
still one of the signatory parties they
are still sitting at the table
conducting the talks in vienna and vs
european union in the person of hrvp as
the coordinator of this agreement are
doing
our best in order to bring these talks
to the successful conclusion
thank you peter do we have any other
questions for peter
foreign affairs
no
do we have non-peter questions so
questions on other topics yes catalin go
ahead
catalin
the floor is yours
yes
finally thank you stefan this is a
question about the humanitarian
assistance
the commission announced the
participation of 26 countries member
states in the eu civil protection
mechanism
hungary is the only country known to
have decided to opt out
but the hungarian authorities deny this
could you clarify how many member states
take part in this cooperation and
whether hungary joined
the mechanism and if it did then
worried what it is doing
under this
mechanism thank you very much thank you
catalin
thank you i can confirm very shortly
that we are at 27 out of 27 when it
comes to the mechanism when it comes to
our response to
the activation of ukraine of the
mechanism going back a couple of weeks
ago
um
i think it's worth putting the whole
thing into context the mechanism was
created in 2001
with the objective of allowing not only
member states but any country around the
world
to ask help from the european union when
they are facing a man-made or a natural
disaster and then the national
capacities are not uh simply sufficient
uh to bring
the response needed now in the past 21
years
the mechanism has been activated on a
very high number of occasions but what
we've never seen is 27 so all eu member
states responding to one um activation
uh request which is the case at this
very moment um i think it's worth saying
that we are talking about 80 million
items which are being offered
to ukraine
these are all of course they all fall
into the category of in-kind assistance
given the high number of items um um
which which we have been talking about
we've also created hubs around ukraine
um namely in poland romania and the
third one being a set up in in slovakia
which serve as a distribution point
towards appropriate um um crossing
points into uh into ukraine so again we
are 27 out of 27 and on top of that
we've also got two um participating
states of the mechanism there are six in
total but two of them have
also responded these are turkey and
norway so 29 countries by the mechanism
sending um humanitarian and civil
protection assistance to ukraine
thank you i think that's absolutely
crystal clear
and do we have any further questions for
barash on humanitarian assistance or on
other parts of his portfolio
no
then are there any other questions for
us today
not in the room
not in interactio
so
thank you very much and do not forget to
follow tomorrow's press conference as i
said before there will be no midday here
thank you have a nice day and stay
healthy
so
you